are you looking to improve the
reproducibility and reliability of your
data science and machine learning
workflows and training jobs then you've
got to try out AI platform pipelines
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we're going to
explore how to set up AI platform
pipelines to address your ML ops needs
Emel ops is all the rage these days a
combination of machine learning and
operations
it applies many DevOps best practices to
the machine learning ecosystem we often
hear about how important it is to have a
well running continuous integration and
deployment pipeline for software
development so as your machine learning
setup matures you should begin to
incorporate these best practices as well
AI platform pipelines allows you to
orchestrate your machine learning
workflows as reproducible and reusable
pipelines specifically it handles the
process of setting up cube foci plans
with tensorflow extended on google
kubernetes engine let's talk a little
more about each of these terms
cube flow is an open source toolkit for
running machine learning workflows on
kubernetes cube flow pipelines is a
component of cube flow that provides a
platform for building and deploying ml
workflows called pipelines structured as
directed acyclic graphs tensorflow
extended or tf-x is also an open source
project which you can use to define your
tensor flow based machine learning
workflows as a pipeline tf-x provides a
pipeline template that includes
components you can reuse to ingest and
transform data train and evaluate a
model deploy a train model for inference
and so on by reusing tf-x components you
can orchestrate your machine learning
process without the need to build custom
components for every single step setting
up AI platform pipelines is quite easy
the team has worked hard to make this
as simple as possible especially for
those who are not familiar with
kubernetes or DevOps there's a dedicated
dashboard for our pipelines in the AI
platform menu in cloud console from
there we can deploy a new pipeline this
button will actually take us to the
cloud marketplace which is the same
place we get our deep learning VM images
after we click launch we are presented
with a configuration page which has two
sections first we need to either create
a kubernetes cluster or select an
existing cluster notice that this is
zone specific if you're creating a new
cluster be sure to check the box to
allow access to cloud api's this action
grants the cluster access to your
project and saves you the effort of
creating and managing a servers account
or creating a kubernetes secret once
that's all set click create cluster and
then wait while the cluster is created
during this time the necessary VMs will
be provisioned the kubernetes cluster
will be created and the kubernetes
software is installed what I really like
about this process is that kubernetes
has been abstracted away and automated
once your cluster is created all we need
to do is give our pipelines instance a
name and click deploy now we wait some
more while the cube flow pipeline
software is installed once pipelines is
deployed to your cluster you end up
mostly working in the pipeline's
dashboard UI the pipeline's dashboard
uses a left-hand navigation bar with a
number of different categories beginning
with getting started which contains a
handful of useful demos and tutorials
with examples of both tf-x
and cube flow pipelines next up is the
pipeline's menu the main event and the
reason we're here we can see a list of
all our pipelines the setup process
deployed a few demo and tutorial
pipelines to the cluster so you can get
started right away
let's start by running the data passing
pipeline by clicking on its name and the
create run button we can include it in
an experiment or just leave the field
blank to associate it with the default
experiment which acts as a capital
notice that this pipeline has no
parameters so we can click start without
entering any additional fields
now we have a pipeline running notice
the dashboard is now showing us the list
of runs in the experiments tab let's
click on our run and see it in progress
notice the graph will animate each
component in the pipeline as it runs
after a little while their job is
finished and the green check replaces
that timer icon pipelines are like
templates they define what needs to be
run but don't represent the actual
execution of code that's what runs are
for you must run a pipeline in order to
get any output each time you run a
pipeline a new set of outputs are
produced these runs are single
executions of a pipeline and individual
runs are associated together into an
experiment you can name your experiments
whatever you want and you're not
constrained to having the same type of
pipeline runs in one experiment so you
can include different types of pipelines
in the same experiment if you want to
running pipelines can output artifacts
these artifacts are viewed by drilling
down into an individual run or by
clicking the artifacts tab in the
left-hand menu cube flow pipelines
supports the following output viewers
currently confusion matrix markdown ROC
curve table tensor board and even a web
app if you really want to get fancy now
you might be thinking this pipelines
thing sounds really awesome but how do I
create my own pipeline at the end of the
day we have two different ways to make
pipelines AI platform pipelines supports
both the tf-x SDK and the cube flow
pipelines SDK how do we choose which one
to use well if you're working with
tensorflow use tf-x
it's designed for tensorflow and will
make your tensorflow code run seamlessly
otherwise use cube flow pipelines it's
designed for any arbitrary library so
you can run everything from your
scikit-learn
models to pi torch in your pipeline tf-x
has the advantage of more pre-built
components and is a more opinionated
approach while cube flow pipelines is
more open-ended and allows you to design
your own pipeline components from
scratch
we'll be looking at more details on how
to use these two SDKs in future episodes
of AI adventures but for now I've
linked to to longer videos exploring AI
platform pipelines in more detail in the
description below thanks for watching
this episode of cloud AI adventures if
you enjoyed it click that like button
and subscribe to get all the latest
episodes right when they come out
I'm Yu Feng Guo on Twitter at U Fang Zhi
and if you're looking for longer form
machine learning and cloud content be
sure to check out the adventures in the
cloud youtube channel which i've linked
below in the description for now try
setting up your very own pipeline on gke
using AI platform pipelines on Google
cloud platform